a plena luz del día y en una zona
tensamente poblada de la ciudad vieja de
nabús el ejército israelí llevó a cabo
una redada a gran escala la más
mortífera junto a la realizada benchina
el 26 de enero pasado según los reportes
locales los soldados israelíes con
francotiradores y camiones blindados
rodearon la vivienda donde se
encontraban sospechosos de haber
participado de un tiroteo en octubre
pasado que causó la muerte de un
Sargento israelí las fuerzas israelíes
lanzaron un misil contra el edificio e
intercambiaron disparos con milicianos
mientras que algunos jóvenes también
arrojaron piedras entre los muertos Más
allá de cuatro integrantes de grupos
armados o dos de ellos de las hijas
islámica Palestina hay víctimas civiles
como un hombre de 72 años y un
adolescente Así mismo los soldados
israelíes arrojaron gran cantidad de
gases lacrimógenos y bombas aturdidoras
que afectaron a los residentes en una
zona de Mercado y en una hora de mucha
concurrencia de ahí que se registraran
más de 100 heridos tanto por los
disparos como consecuencia de los gases
y entre ellos hay tres periodistas que
sufrieron heridas de bala rápidamente un
Vocero de la presidencia de la autoridad
de Palestina condenó lo que calificó de
crimen de la ocupación y llamó a Estados
Unidos a ejercer presión sobre Israel
mientras que desde gaza el grupo
islamista jamás Es que gobiernan la
franja aseguró que se está acabando la
paciencia así ya son al menos 59 los
palestinos muertos por fuego israelí
solo en 2023 y bajo Un gobierno de
ultraderecha que endurece las redadas y
las medidas punitivas tras la muerte de
once personas en ataques en Jerusalén
este la violencia es cada vez peor